لذلك اعتقدت حسنًا ، يمكنني نقع و
قال بوتين أننا لا نستطيع امتصاصه
المشكلة ليست المرة الأولى لذلك
ثانيًا ، أقول لا تفعل ذلك بسبب
أنه لن تكون هناك مفاوضات
هؤلاء الرجال الذين يعرفون بعضهم البعض
الوقوف الذي قادوه هناك وفي إفريقيا
قاتلت أمريكا اللاتينية أنها ستستمر
يمكننا أيضًا نقع كل شيء لآلاف الآلاف
المسالمون سيموتون والذين سيموتون
مقاومة Wagners ليست في هذه الحالة
الأبطال لا ، نقول بصدق
يقع اللوم على بوتين لعدم قبوله في الوقت المحدد
مقاسات
لذلك لا أحد هنا بطل
أعتقد أنني قلت فقط ماذا لو
ستنهار روسيا ، وسنبقى هناك
حطام
سنهلك جميعًا ؛ ثانيًا ، هذا هو مركزنا
الحضارة بقدر ما نود
إذا لم تغش الفئران فنحن هكذا
كل الانواع
نحن مميزون نحن مستقلون لدينا
خططهم أفكارهم وهلم جرا ولكن
هذه حضارتنا مشتركة لكني لا أعرف
كيف